Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
reciban un cordial saludo desde París en
este nuevo número de nuestro programa
donde les hablaremos de las principales
noticias de la cultura en Francia
[Música]
kiustoffel matisse saga Bernard Marcel
marzo Pablo Picasso o ramses 2 ellos
serán los grandes protagonistas del año
cultural en Francia
la prensa internacional entregó los
premios lumière al cine francés la noche
del 12 fue distinguida como la mejor
película francesa del 2022
como muere una marioneta fuimos a buscar
una respuesta en el espectáculo trágico
de la compañía canadiense de old Shop
y en nuestra Crónica musical conoceremos
a un Dúo que combina Funk y french Dodge
se llaman Yoyo
nicholson y nos hablaron de su trabajo
[Música]
comenzamos dándoles un adelanto de los
principales acontecimientos y
celebraciones culturales que tendrán
lugar en los próximos 12 meses en
Francia eventos de los que les estaremos
hablando por supuesto a lo largo del año
en Carrusel de las artes nos amplía
Melissa barra
[Música]
el año que comienza estará repleto de
celebraciones culturales en Francia el
maestro del color y Matiz será
homenajeado con una exposición en el
Museo de París una muestra que se
concentra en la producción de los años
30 Es decir entre las dos guerras
mundiales
el petipalé abrirá sus alas para una
gran retrospectiva sobre la actriz
francesa de teatro saga Bernard la diva
de la Belle époque más de 400 objetos
compondrán esta exposición que busca
explorar la vida íntima de esta artista
multifacética Francia recordará también
a Marcel quien pasó a la historia como
el mimo más extraordinario de todos los
tiempos y Quien fuera fuente de
inspiración para muchos artistas
posteriores
el artífice del cubismo Pablo Picasso
ser objeto de numerosas exposiciones con
motivo del 50 aniversario de su muerte
la capital francesa se rendirá al
exuberante tesoro de ramses El Grande a
través de la muestra Ramsés y el oro de
los faraones que se instalará en la
villette con objetos que se mostrarán
por primera vez fuera de
egiptometro Francia conmemorará por todo
lo alto a su ingeniero más ilustreustav
y fel con el motivo del centenario de su
muerte y Carrusel de las artes los
llevará a descubrir algunas de sus obras
más emblemáticas Empezando por la
icónica torre que se convirtió en el
símbolo de la ciudad luz
el año comenzó en Francia con la entrega
de los premios lumière de la prensa
extranjera al cine francés las figuras
más destacadas estuvieron en esa velada
y nuestros micrófonos estuvieron allí
los premios Luis Miguel fueron los
primeros galardones del año al cine
francés
La Academia lumeas que reúne los
críticos de la prensa internacional en
Francia designó a la noche del 12 como
la mejor película francesa y mejor guión
del 2022 un Thriller sin culpable sobre
el asesinato de una chica y del
investigador que transforma este caso en
una obsesión su director Dominique Mall
[Música]
Tratamos de hacer una película que
reflejara el sentir de las mujeres pero
también sobre la masculinidad muchas
mujeres nos han dicho que es una
película feminista y no las voy a
contradecir si ellas reciben así pero lo
que queríamos explorar es lo que se
genera en la cabeza de este investigador
Joan quien no logra alucinar el crimen y
a través de su personaje abordar la
violencia de otros personajes masculinos
y como él reacciona en esa situación
[Música]
la cinta Franco española asbestas fue
distinguida como la mejor coproducción
internacional este tráiler rural de
atmósferas asfixiante es la gran
favorita de los Goya en España pero todo
comenzó con el homicidio de un campesino
extranjero en un pueblo de Galicia y el
comportamiento de su viuda nos lo dijo
el director y co guionista de esta cinta
el español Rodrigo sorogolling como una
extranjera que va a un sitio alejado de
su país a priori no muy cómodo Y donde
he recibido muy mal donde le dicen por
activa y por pasiva que no la quieren ni
a ella ni evidentemente su pareja que
además acaba muerto en tragedia Porque
esa mujer se queda como no conocíamos la
respuesta queríamos acercarnos por lo
menos no a intentar entender ese
comportamiento y ese es el principal
motor de la película realmente
él siempre disruptivo al ver Serra alzó
el premio al mejor director por
pacifixión cinta hipnótica filmada en la
Polinesia francesa y que como sus
anteriores trabajos rompe con las
convenciones visuales y narrativas
es un cine donde se intenta como mínimo
no simplificar la vida ni darle como
unos mensajes a priori y llegamos
satisfacer al espectador en sus digamos
necesidades más banales el protagonista
de pacifixión se llevó el premio de
interpretación masculina y Virginia
llega el de la mejor actriz por su papel
en los hijos de los otros
[Música]
y del cine Vamos al teatro de marionetas
para descubrir una compañía única en el
mundo la canadiense de old pupped
workshop que es ha sido famosa por sus
creaciones Y en especial con un
espectáculo trágico pero lleno de humor
y no apto para el público infantil
[Música]
quien dijo que las marionetas son solo
para los niños las hay también macabras
asesinas o depresivas ellas son las
protagonistas de este espectáculo
trágico cómico la muerte grandiosa de
las marionetas en las que todas pasan a
mejor vida la marionetista Luis Ashton
el espectáculo tiene 26 escenas de
marionetas muriendo que sea por muerte
natural asesinato o suicidio todas las
muertes son diferentes pueden ser
violentas a tétricas tristes o
sorpresivas y a veces son solo graciosas
y todo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los autores de esta comedia buscaron en
todo el mundo referencias de
espectáculos de marionetas con escenas
de muerte y la única que encontraron
está en Pinocho en el cuento italiano
original Pinocho mata el grillo cuando
adaptaron la obra al teatro de
marionetas con el asesinato del grillo
la reacción del público fue sorprendente
se dieron cuenta de que era algo por
explorar así que crearon este
espectáculo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
detrás de esta masacre en serie 3
marionetistas y muchos recursos visuales
la actriz haya nakamura no marihuana en
un espectáculo tradicional tienes pocas
marionetas pero aquí tenemos casi 30
marionetas distintas es bastante difícil
acostumbrarse a todas y mostrar sus
diferentes formas de morir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y pasamos ahora a nuestro segmento
dedicado a la música presentado como
siempre por Natalia Olivares Hola
Natalia para esta primera Crónica del
año nos propones hacer una escala
musical con un Dúo Funk de la friend
Touch que saca su tercer álbum Yoyo no
nicholson con este nuevo álbum Plus es
un homenaje a msd el poeta e ideólogo
del concepto de la negritud nos habla de
esa receta del éxito de este Dúo
Dinámico que es Mezclar un poco de todo
pero en proporciones exactas
[Música]
nos gustan todos los estilos de música y
no queríamos quedarnos atrapados en una
sola casilla nos encanta todo y no
renunciamos a nada Es cierto que hay un
color que emerge de todas estas mezclas
pero no queremos limitarnos al hip hop o
hacer puro Funk y en esta mezcla lo que
resalta es el ritmo pero sobre todo nos
gusta que las palabras suenen en francés
Es nuestra lengua materna o idioma
francés arritmico y nosotros hacemos que
las palabras se muevan con la música eso
es cierto hay ritmo hay
[Música]
y lo crea el YouTube es el teniente de
la música yuyoa El capitán de las
palabras en este álbum Plus hay muchos
temas como la ecología la violencia la
policía y África yoyoa nos cuenta esa
conexión esta alquimia con el público
cuando regresamos a Sudáfrica cantamos
en el recinto de Constitución Hill donde
estuvo preso Nelson Mandela y allí nos
sorprendimos porque la gente cantaba las
letras en francés de nuestra canciones
en particular que hay piriñas que había
sonado en todas las radios locales hay
una conexión que se ha hecho con nuestra
audiencia que no podemos explicarme
[Música]
notar que es muy difícil Traducir esos
textos esa complicidad lleno de juegos
de palabras pero entendí bien escuche
bien dijo que hay piriña caipirinha
Bueno ahí hay que explicar cada cosa que
hay en francés de la calle significa
hace frío así es que sacáis piriña
simple bueno y hay otros temas también
en este álbum un tema importante que es
la lentitud
la idea viene de una observación durante
la crisis de la covid las vidas se
calmaron y vamos más despacio nos
tomamos el tiempo para observar en
Italia vimos delfines en Venecia por
ejemplo nos dio tiempo para verlos para
nosotros era importante decir que hay
que tomarse el tiempo para hacer las
cosas es así como resultan y queríamos
tratar este tema con un ritmo Funky para
bailar con la lentitud
[Música]
una un elogio a la lentitud era la
chispa que le faltaba a la escena
francesa un Duo lento pero seguro Bueno
y con esta oda a la lentitud a que nos
Proponen estos artistas vamos a despedir
Este programa Natalia agradeciéndoles a
todos por su sintonía y invitándolos a
que nos escuchen en el próximo Carrusel
de las artes Mercy
[Música]